[Music]
how do I feel I feel pretty solid I feel
like there's some nuances that are
indicating good Felicity other than the
fact that Instagram is organic reach is
finished so just as we figured it out
it's over it's over
you got your perspective
[Music]
do you know me people have emailed me in
the last and when I say email DM Dada
in the last hundred days that have said
to me I cannot believe how many
followers I have on tick-tock
after seven years of going hard on
YouTube and Instagram within 31 days I
have a bigger audience more impactful on
my happiness or my business results on
tick-tock thank you
so I'm just gonna [ __ ] put the
blueprint out for free I'm putting out
the whole [ __ ] game the map the
[ __ ] key the blueprint what do you
want to call it the crystal Bob you
wanna call it I'm putting now for zero
point zero zero cents and then I'm gonna
let the cards play out I can't worry
about if I'm gonna get you to get to do
it I'm just gonna pressure you in
perpetuity to put in your [ __ ] face
that it can be done
you're the [ __ ] maps here's the
[ __ ] blueprint and I'm just gonna
wait for person on person a person every
day can't believe I just went on
Facebook part yes sir just want a
facebook blog place maybe 200 bucks I
can't believe it but let's think I
already say this for 18 months I finally
did it Wow tick tock LinkedIn like I'm
gonna put out 3 game for the rest of my
[ __ ] life and when it's all over a
lot of [ __ ] people can do something
about it which is why everyone's coming
to my funeral and I'll be really really
mad if you don't come alright I'll be
real mad at you specifically hurry
[Music]
do you want to do the vo that we were
talking about need to be predict op if
your customer base is older how to use
tiptoe what so many people are scared to
do and one of the things I see people
scared to do is jump on a new platform
when it's emerging and they're worried
about wasting time will it still be
around will be big that's always a bad
idea because there's so many learnings
and if it's potentially huge one out of
eight times that will pay for all your
other seven times wasted however if you
right now target you know 50 to 80 year
olds it doesn't mean that you have to be
on tick-tock I'm very comfortable that
if you're targeting 50 to 80 year olds
for mortgages that tick tock makes a lot
less sense than LinkedIn that's when you
maybe spend point 1 percent of your
strategy and time looking at it
I do think you should get an account I
do think that you maybe should look at
it why because LinkedIn may create a
feature a meme or story feature that
maybe something you've seen in tick tock
makes you create better on LinkedIn you
know if you're targeting 14 to 18
year-olds trying to sell them
hoodies you should be spending 50 to 70
percent of your time on tick tock so yes
these are not blanket statements and if
you have an older demo I have no problem
with you not doing it
quote-unquote to me that is one percent
of your time downloading the app and
looking for human behavior tactics and
nuances that may help you in the places
you do market you may hear a term on
tick tock that changes the term you use
in the title of your email that makes
that email convert four percent better
you understand that's awful
gives up car buying advice good advice
is not required to stay in any room you
can get good advice on LinkedIn you can
get good advice on tick-tock you can get
good vice in the corner at a cafe you
know good content has no boundaries of
distribution I mean the tick-tock thing
is playing out right in everyone's
[ __ ] face the [ __ ] clip we just
put on Instagram what the gentleman just
said on the podcast and everyone's like
reacting because for a lot of people
it's their first rodeo and I'm like I've
[ __ ] seen this movie before
Oh works every eleven-year-olds gonna be
about the content there are universal
truths and we post produce we think
about the music we think about the the
meme overlay we think
that's right especially the context
understanding the context of the
distribution that is the slang that is
the culture like you have to you have to
know what you want to say you have to
know the culture right you have to know
what is cool you have to know that a
sneak and slap means something to an 18
year old in Atlanta and then you have to
know how to actually make it for
Instagram to public it's a three prong
attack just somebody were to ask you
what what you would recommend in order
to understand the culture or the next
week listen follow 700 accounts download
the app follow all the things that
Explorer or pops up in your feed search
cars wine sneakers lawyers search your
thing
follow 53 accounts that show up in those
hashtags of your thing open the app
every day for 10 minutes consume consume
consume consume then talk want to make
sure I give this to you as well so my
stepdaughter is 12 and I listen to your
podcast when my wife and I are on the
car and they're watching movies in the
back and I didn't realize she had
stumbled across you on tick tock and had
yeah right
and she put two and two together that
the podcast that I was listening to was
Gary she found out I was coming on her
own right before I left she said please
give this to Gary what's her name
my name is Rhys Rhys I have it Rhys how
are you it's Gary Vee this is incredible
if you want to start a business with me
selling your drawings I'm in if you do
not produce content for YouTube LinkedIn
and Facebook every day as a real estate
and Instagram as a real estate or
mortgage professional you're losing
figure it out that's a big statement I
know that's I'm scare you haven't posted
anything I'm asking you for [ __ ]
platforms a day go Google go learn how
do I post on YouTube
I'm giving you the statement there I
don't need to give you tactics my
friends it's called Google you don't
know how to make a video Google I don't
even know what Final Cut Pro is I could
figure everything they all do I can do
in a day it's called Google actually for
me it's YouTube I can't read for [ __ ]
I'd have to watch it but I know keep
yourself at god I hate [ __ ] I hate
people that talk something they don't
live plenty of leaders talking about
keep learning every day yet refuse to
[ __ ] learn we before I think we
started the podcast cuz I don't think
whatever's here we talked about your
daughter you know knowing who I am I'm
living my truth I tell you to keep doing
it I keep doing it I've got a million
followers on tik-tok that's not [ __ ]
bragging about my following on Tic Tac
that's me living my [ __ ] truth take
that didn't cross my mind on January 1st
actually did but it wasn't ready
[Music]
good afternoon
yep afternoon uh I'm just sending you a
text to [ __ ] make this this is about
making let's thinking ideas of making
just [ __ ] make do you wanna just real
quick actually record once you done
there record the same thing but for
tick-tock specifically no no gotta do a
couple other things I know what I'm
feeling like everyone's doing well
except you
and Lou and possibly feel it as well but
everybody else is not in this car is
[ __ ] crushing you oh and AH be
struggling and I'm the [ __ ] worst how
do I feel
I feel pretty solid I feel like there's
some nuances that are indicating good
felicity other than the fact that
Instagram is organic we just finished
so just as we figured it out it's over
it's over
yeah organic reach on Instagram has
started the process of it being over so
now everyone's about to be everyone's
influence for careers about that and
what's up print I'm now talking to you
how's everything at wine texts
[Music]
tick tock the same phenomenon is
happening on tick tock I have empathy
why a lot of people will say well that
is not where my audience is but that
would be because people are playing
checkers and they're not playing chess
and they don't realize that the number
one influencer on buying things in
America is the mom and the person that
influences the mom the most is the
daughter you could have an entire
strategy on targeting fourteen-year-old
girls on tick-tock to make a business
transaction happen with the mom you
could a you have to have the strategy
and the knowledge to know what I just
said is true too
you then have to put out content that
inspires a fourteen-year-old to tell
their mom about it which is no easy task
that's a creative struggle you have to
be very clever but it's not impossible
but the amount of organic reach on that
platform and for whatever reason if your
side house or your actually job creates
a world where you're trying to market to
12 to 18 year-olds you should be
spending 50 to 70 percent of your time
on tick tock the growth is uncomfortable
and it is the only platform right now in
the world that has the potential to
dethrone Instagram as the top app in
culture it may not act age up the way
that vine and you know Socialcam and
others did not but it might because I
will remind all of you that Instagram
started off as a app to help people take
better photos and had filters or
Facebook was a College only social
network these things they jump so this
is what I spend all my time on
underpriced attention
[Music]
video Facebook live what's good oh it's
hi viewers - my favorite number 5 what's
good Paul
shin what's good shin see ya uncle
girlfriend uncle who's Paul that's my
uncle Oh who's Bubba
he's the og MACO goog my [ __ ] oh that's
my girl
watch so who's Jessica I don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's some real good clips there if
you didn't miss them I think the
funniest one is the one where I
graduates go live say that it's five
people we go through all the people and
I thought Jess was his girlfriend he
goes nuts my girlfriend they go well
who's Jess the first person he didn't
catch it he goes I don't know hey Jess
and I want to title it wait for it cuz
you'll have no clue how it that will
kill it's kind of like that the big mean
of all time right where it's like the
guy walking with the girl looking back
getting on the girl oh I think it has
crazy potential call it a little and
tell him am I going to real estate
conferences or anytime I am to tell you
you know what I mean and he will he's
good like that little Lou's pretty
organized really you don't think you're
already nice little oh really
you're fired I mean you're finish low
your time well I'm so not organized that
everyone who anybody who's like put
something into a pool calendar but is
like you're very organized no nobody
thinks I'm organized
a great day in the city sort of vlog
vlog a bunch of big quotes hopefully
Caleb and d-roc didn't miss it
Liu made a cameo now not on trash talks
which is rare you love my Josh talk now
he's in that many like if you love them
a trash talk um really sharp dead go and
have an Operations meeting now
for three hours which is a lot of stuff
you guys don't see three you know and
and just feeling good feeling feel
excited hopefully Sam darn old spleen
will get cleared on Friday and some good
news today from that practicing
I'm not sure see I hope you enjoy
subscribe leave a comment to one two
nine three one five seven three one text
me the text I just said of like just
make somebody took it put into it and
said find a significant other who
supports you the way Gary that's well
done
you